you
all right we got one minute there he is
the Ferrari he's like okay I'll enter
right at the start I'll let it be known
I'll let it be known the Ferrari is in
there all right hey you know what it
can't get any worse than how it started
in the last tournament last tournament
ended with a smothered mate so as long
as I avoid the smothered mate and h2
getting fishing pulled we'll be all
right all right I feel like I already
have to be pre moving right now whoa I
almost berserk Ferrari are you kidding
oh he purrs irk me that was a mouse lip
okay we're both in berserk mode and we
have a closed position I did not want to
do this oh yeah just Brizard Ferrari
right dropping that pond dropping e4 is
he going to take it he takes it i mouse
slipped I'm dropping another pawn let's
defend him what an amazing start amazing
um and a pin terribleness terribleness
but it's a time time race just go fast
maybe let's go here not quite sure why
all right push some pawns push through
take here
um okay he's got to take there no oh boy
my Kings gonna get killed
yikes I want to take the rook like Oh
where's my good grief that determines ah
you know there was more time I could
have sworn there was it jumped the gun
and I was just I was pretending there's
a little backstory here those watching
in YouTube I'm just talking about oh I
feel like I need to start pre moving
because I knew I was going to get paired
up with Ferrari and I was pretending
that I was going to pre move and then
the tournament started a little bit too
soon and my mouse just happened to be
right where the berserk button was Oh
against the world's fastest player the
Ferrari oh man okay you got a regroup
regroup okay
defend your Center would you Wow
all right let's queenside castle let's
get some Primo's in there would you get
some pre moves in here got a pre move
more take this Knight
oh I'm going to pin okay save let's grab
this guy okay
Bishop here no matter what may be unless
King e7 let's just smash this open get
some more pre moves in maybe push okay
let's give this check here my block with
the Queen another pre move mate soon
mate back to tournament whoo okay we
have 74 players in here and I got two
there's a game to lose it's the first
one all right let's go here let's stay
focused and throw a gambit play gambit
chess how about that not my style but
we're going to mix it up there we go
watch out watch out for tricks here it's
not working in a castle and this isn't
working they just open it up with d5 all
right let's just castle take that pawn
okay maybe I gain a temple against the
Queen at some point like right now at
this point right here uh he's an
important pawn I'll hang on till now
alright let's kick him around alright
preparing f5 alright not just yet
bishop here fi very soon very soon f6
break at these dark squares looking for
mate matin one rook g8 take and push
fish up on f6 Bishop f6 incoming I could
have pushed this is mate though into I
see it now it's unstoppable
hitting h7 they're down and earned
enough down time they resigned back to
term at doctor chess it's a mouse slip
let's get this in here mmm
let's go some more pre moves
let's get c4 in let's also play Queen e2
now let's take first my not winning
material mmm
no cam winning material mmm or am I
let's take here first that's check I
think they might have had Knight takes
let's do this I want to pawn I'm on the
rook get this Bishop out of here soon
they're going to take my bishop here
okay
let's throw this in let's get my queen
over where they are in trouble okay
we're just going to trade I should have
done something else defend get my king
over here and then rook here just
dropping upon let's keep him around I'm
playing too much on time maybe okay I'm
getting a pawn back I have pressure on
the a pawn
let's take him first and now track down
the F pawn ah let's save him
if I can all right that's a check
umm-hmm let's go here which was not a
good move
alright let's save him not playing this
well
let's keep pushing here are they back in
time they are I played this very very
poorly very poorly okay I don't want to
push that pawn again I come over with my
king okay I pressure in that pond
King has to hide now oh wow
barely lucky lucky is what I meant what
am I talking about barely let's give a
check another check and then mate
they're down on time back determine okay
to be expected wild and craziness 15 I'm
at eight I got to keep going fast maybe
going a little too fast in that when
giving just spoiling up giving away
every pawn in that rook and pawn ending
23 minutes remaining a lot of time 19
points he just finished so we might get
paired up again nope
alright let's let's get some early pre
moves in here g6 no matter what here
unless Bishop h6 all right let's get d6
in let's go Bishop here and then take
the knight and then get my b5 pawn
rolling I could take on b2 if they take
twice okay I could win the exchange I
don't want to go for that I'm going to
hit at c4 maybe e6 night here hitting c4
again that's difficult to defend c4 is
collapsing a knight on this square is
huge and I'll take with this nut keep
pressure on here hitting there bishop
take and then take here let's occupy the
file capture my Queens hit again I'll go
Queen c7 just challenged this file here
f4 Knight d7 they can take my a pawn I
have a big time edge maybe I just get
pushed
the pond yep let's go with him Knight d3
my bishop is free now queen bee for
quite Queen b6 I'm hitting f2 the knight
has to move again Knight b2 c3 dark
squares are collapsing bishop here
probably no matter what fortunately my
queen was defended and now I'm getting
this misters push here they resigned
back to tournament 29 29 16 12 12 21
minutes remain already okay let's see
how we're doing here 76 players
Ferrari kpop V sit kpop all right let's
get some moves in here let's take and
play d5 okay they're gonna give up the
bishop pair alright I'm in a pin let's
get out of this pin as soon as possible
challenge that guy maybe move my knight
let's do this let's see how they want to
take take here that's a good move let's
do this here I'm hitting this they could
get this pawn I get their pawn in the
center okay they are going for that I
think that was an okay exchange take on
V to challenge this file and get right
here very active pieces just go for
active play my bishops are really really
strong this pawn here I want to get
behind the pawns actually I could take
this pawn right now and let's go here
just defend I don't want to move my
bishop my King up there not moving
keep going King towards the center clamp
down in their structure alright let's go
here
ee v break it there bishop move my
bishop with check that's actually mate
back to tournament 29 1616 check that 33
he just finished we're probably going to
get paired up yay or nay I got to put a
dent in his streak
okay let's see how we do here let's
throw the H pawn at them and see how he
reacts to that okay hit this pawn play
in the center if they take I'll be on
that pond okay let's go back get my
night doing something hit at this pawn
not hitting at it twice I'm on there
beep on there dark squares are very
weakened hmm okay what's that move I
want to get castled either Queen this is
a very good position for me let's castle
first I have a very good check right
here and let's take once I get on this
file no trade get my pieces active I
just drop my knight
let's take here defend my knight over
here hit their queen oh I missed that I
keep the Queen on the board though Queen
here Queen B - umm Queen here stops pawn
push it's a very nasty discovered check
that's a double check I got the Queen
how's my clock I have a time edge just
break this position down where's the
mate clean here got the rook let's check
almost mate finally
good grief at a time edge - gotta start
pre moving more 33 20 18 18 someone else
has to knock him down I think I might
get paired up with AH Madan he just
finished 30 320 320 no let's go efore no
matter what that's the hope is play okay
I'm on their night I'm in check let's
develop development is important ah man
these comments they're just unnecessary
unnecessary his queen gonna be trapped
where's she going
she's having a tough day think b5 next
no that's got to be painful that night
alright okay let's go here Knight c4
I'll give up the exchange of dark
squares are incredibly weak hit the rook
hit the rook again threatening mate
Bishop c4 and mate threat back on take
the night going g7 they resigned back to
tournament that was a quick win thirty
three twenty four twenty three eighteen
sixteen minutes remaining the bull Slav
ski alrighty let's see how I get paired
up with there are seventy nine players
now enter the Ferrari again let's go
with the Sicilian alright let's take
let's give a check maybe here castle I
should have maybe taken earlier exchange
no let's focus on the dark squares fish
up here now let's do that I could take
and beyond their Queen if Bishop d6 here
Queen d4 it's a bit annoying I could do
this
there's no for Conde to got a kick that
night out huh this is scary
go back
okay this night what a great bother I
just dropped my pawn they didn't see it
they're going to move the ref pawn here
I guess get out of pins
don't do anything tricky night Ms
happening soon oh boy oh okay go here
hit the a pond and then maybe the bishop
on their Bishop I also have night here
hitting the Queen and the rook it's
probably way out Queen CA or that move I
have a strong point on a d4 Stefan here
hit the night get him out of there I
thought he was trapped let's trade one
piece and push my a pawn
keep pushing
kick that rook out of there get this
pawn don't drop your knight hit their
Bishop maybe a clock situation is usual
not good get my Brooke active don't get
mated six seconds just dropped a piece
and I get it back
where's the mate is there a mate
Perpetual oh that's not working
nope not happening back to tournament
down on time and position of course ah
okay ooh he actually had back-to-back
losses there okay um thirty five thirty
one twenty five twenty four so I was not
the only one to put a dent in his uh
streak there no squeaky clean
performance this time around
alright oh I wanted to take alright
and I wanted to go c4 maybe we could get
one move in without it being a mouse
slip
all right I was going to play h4
regardless of the Jeep on pushing just
caveman stuff all right let's play in
this direction pressure on the night one
of them will be pinned maybe we break in
there Center now let's give this check
and then come back maybe push the pawn
in b5 let's go inside Castle first
though that still might be strong no
trades Knight f3 hit this pond right
here tough to defend it's doing in
between or Knight here as well let's do
that hitting everything and we'll take
this rook so you could run away give up
the light square bishop they'll be very
weak on the light squares let's go here
open up the C file King b1 maybe take
the bishop take on 87 I want my rook on
c1 I didn't even see that they moved
take like this their bishops dead has to
go right into the corner I want to open
up the light squares or the diagonal
here umm get to the 7th oh I thought it
was my king right there don't fall for
me please I'm hitting the bishop let's
take a pawn first let's take here bishop
check and then here I just want to lock
down on that rook want to round up that
pawn not easy to do yeah it is actually
Hans running take the bishop they're
down a time and see that 42:35 29 26 11
minutes repin Tremaine okay let's see
42:35 33 26 all right no not so fast
okay oh they're going with f5 very
weakening I just do what happened there
alright we're going to try we're going
to try
g4 alright if they're king
okay g6 I push let's develop my knight
first and let's get queenside castle
maintain this pawn here save my Jeep on
probably push next let's hang on to him
it's probably important d4 I go here
night before I take them out okay let's
come over here he's at a very important
pond I'm on here Bishop e3 Knight here
could take this pawn could have taken
that pond like so many times let's get
rid of this Knight
alright let's come over here I want to
hunt this pawn down let's push them okay
let's finally take that pond and give up
the two rooks we're going to see pretty
much have to go in for now I need
coordination preparing to double rooks
now I can get the Queen soon maybe like
right now actually got the Queen improve
the King physician don't lose your
bishop here here just recapture push
keep improving have a more outside pass
pawn run it like this that pond there
and then just mop up these pawns and
push through with the a pond plenty of
time
no stalemates to Queens on the board and
that should be mate next they resign
back to tournament forty six forty three
thirty three twenty eight nine minutes
remain okay eighty two players are now
entered in this one he has to be knocked
off again Oh Madonn is maybe the one who
put a dent in him fishing pole stuff I
usually go in this direction out of this
opening
we'll see there is Bishop there 'if I've
is not working I have enough defense the
bishop moves my queen is hit let's get
some more development in let's get out
of the line of fire and let's secure b5
keep my queen on this diagonal okay I
could have taken that pawn okay he is
free I get to keep him now I'll take the
knight I'm on there Bishop as well I
have this square covered from checks
just want to get castled let's hang on
to this pond b5 I thought Queen here
just trade make sure I have a flight
square soon okay if they take I get to
under my pawns now let's just do this
I'm giving up some material just to get
some exchanges okay I can recapture and
defend d4 okay the Queen was the leader
for that one it might be resigned they
resigned back to tournament 47 46 33 32
is where I stand
seven minutes in change this one I think
I have already more points that I did in
the last tournament um
32 okay no no no no no let's get this in
this bishops trapped c4 I take let's go
d5 take with the pond okay
okay I see I see a mate happening soon
with a knight g3 H 5 H 4 Knight g3
leading to mate let's go here if they
take the pawn I'm playing h5 I'm setting
it up Knight g3 is a deadly move okay
they have to give up their queen taking
it upon its mate this is mate one of
these two the Knight has to block that's
me on each to back to tournament 5149
36e for less than seven minutes remain
quick kill scholars
stuff I felt like I could have done that
catch them in a pre move I might have
been able to do that I might have been
able to do it I should have tried Knight
year okay we're going to have an ending
not quiet let's stop Knight d4 I have
the bishop pair let's kick him around
grab some Queen side space 85 okay
got to get my dark square bishop playing
and maybe Queen here all right let's
stop that that wasn't a threat let's
play here okay let's get to the D file
when are they going to cat when are they
going to castle take with the Queen
watch over my dark squares that's a
check I want to kick this rook away
let's do it right now
let's recapture first Queen checks here
bit scary let's go here defend my pawn
if the Queen get to the seventh rank
Queen trade okay get to the seventh rank
even on the clock if that night and a
push I have to square covered with my
bishops we can't defend the night
well rook here actually they didn't go
for it okay I have this covered
still they push and miss that they
missed that my bishop was covering give
this check here no matter what okay
let's give a check push up I'm good on
the clock let's get behind here keep
pushing grab this pawn give a check next
just to get the move back keep going
fast okay they're in check and they
resign back determent no I don't want to
withdraw I'm still in the tournament get
back in there join okay
having the carol all righty let's get
Bishop here castle look there throw a
question to the bishop I trade some take
the bishop if he goes to g6 okay I'm
playing with the bishop pair let's
secure d4 let's trade one piece right
here maybe push soon not just yet
Knights going to reposition no giving me
a kick first I could push right away
let's cover this square actually queen
of five might be a move as well I feel
like this is right covering a lot of
squares with my bishops real lot b5 I'm
on g5 let's trade let's open this up for
the bishops take on b7 I have a time
edge let's keep him on his home Square
keep pushing recapture with check get my
bishop off of that same file there
Knight is dead another bishop check move
my bishop push my pawn bishop check here
on post Bishop c5 let's go here first
let's give a check and no trades keep
pieces on the board I have a big time
edge move the bishop discovered
checkmate soon the bishop has to block
and then it's made they resigned back to
tournament 60 60 60 they both they both
have 60s 44 is where I'm at less than 3
minutes remaining
let's take and play d5 it's recapture
Knight f6 more pre moves is what is
needed these tournaments let's throw a
knight in the center throw some punches
secure my Knight position if takes I get
the F file opposite the Queen I might
put pressure here okay I have discovered
tricks Knight takes here after the
knight moves everything
is collapsing now Queens hit twice get
pushing here and I'm winning some more
material let's move forward and take
that pawn just retreat probably with
something better there Queen here move
forward hit it g2 let's check and then
pond okay that's mate back to Turman 65
60 48 less than two minutes remain
that's probably how it's going to finish
up okay let's see if we could still get
another one in here all right let's take
recapture c4 hit it f7 maybe dislodge
the knight Bishop f4 kh3 soon Bishop e6
I drop back okay I gave up my dark
square Bishop they might shatter my
queen side structure let's prepare for
f4 he needs to be dislodged Bishop back
I push and now I'm getting something
because I have this in-betweener I'm on
the Queen and the rook and the bishop
that's what's check take here and then
give this check soon or just trade
Queens I'm up a full rook rook and a
knight
take this pawn they resigned back to
tournament less than 40 seconds don't
know that we're going to get paired up
sixty nine sixty 52 and yeah I don't
think it's a it's going to pair us up
anymore
86 players in this one no one with a
squeaky clean performance at least from
what I could tell up top here
interesting games 15 seconds and yeah
these games are all going maybe we could
sneak in and see a game see the Ferrari
in action is he playing
if he is I can't see it quick enough
all right and that's how it finishes up
final tally there sixty nine sixty fifty
two thirty seven thirty to thirty one
let's uh work this in so we could see
all the players that took part in this
there were 86 at the end of it all it's
page two
what let's try this again
page two three and so forth all righty
and that's all 86 all right to the 86 of
you that took part in this GG's all
alright
you